are is this a specific to rap contest or
is it just it was open to anything but
uh they were both kind of wrapped the
second guy sang a little bit more would
you compare it to like uh uh everlasting
everlast oh that's sad
[Music]
this guy's winning
[Music]
are we rolling i'm gonna vote for the
other i'm gonna double check but yeah
let's roll double yo yo what's up yeah
yeah yeah it's your boy chapelle lacy
dj envy angela lee he's charlemagne the
god i tried to do this this is the
breakfast
i stumbled on it i [ __ ] it up welcome
back to another episode of caps after
dark this is what our thousandth
episode thousandth episode we've done
uh the whole crew is here we got a
little brows in the house yeah i guess i
got to give a special introduction to
the white man the other white person in
this room don't recognize not enough
whites for my taste as as christians
just walking around
hey the man the man of the hour the
menace in the house come on now my
roommate stand up comedian
uh my main credit is roommate though
yeah the main credit is what you were
talking about me until you said
trying to move in the lower room l.a
freaking white mike hey yo this is
listen
can i say this i'll say it anyway
this is the hardest [ __ ] bengals fan
i think i've ever met oh come on in my
entire life this man wore a bengals
outfit to the super bowl hold on hold on
hold on
they lost the super bowl a man had to
walk out the stadium with that bingo
outfit on well he did not take it off i
mean if it was not taking it off as any
other team than the rams i would have
been worried you did not take it off but
those rams fans were soft you kept that
[ __ ] on yeah i kept it those weights i
mean it was cold at night
i got a layer of fur
i know those la nights get crazy yeah
the l.a knights get crazy and plus
bengals they handle that kind of
environment no yeah i thought if it was
raven steelers there's like some team
that like actually had a fan base i'd be
scared
packers fans would have been wild
oh you're saying nine yeah you guys are
probably midwest friendly niners i
actually was scared if it was niners
bengals niners fans are crazy aggressive
and oakland fans we know but now they're
basically we already know i didn't know
okay so the rams fan they were cool with
you they were they didn't even know
they'd won you know what
do you think rams fans are super left
i think rams fans are just wrong
[Music]
i don't know they're not even real fans
are they just like they're just fake
fans they're just fake fans they just
they just realize that the team's here
you know yeah they're just like real
woke they don't know oh yeah football
team nah because there's some orange
county energy in there there's some
orange county there's some people japan
yeah there's there's some people that
understand tax breaks yeah and like
laguna beach yes there's some newport
beach energy in newport beach um if
you're trying to find a nice maga rally
yeah
yeah that was the first time that was
the first time a lot of those people
were blue
but nah they didn't care oh that's not
his profile it's mike turner comedy or
turtle yeah turning company turner
comedy is his profile he got some bingo
oh dude uh outfits on there you keep
saying bingles they're bangles oh am i
saying it wrong i do think that's a
black thing
is it not to you know
generalize your whole race
like my chris brought on the podcast dog
yeah
as a wife
we go hardy
no we bro the funniest thing
so one of the funniest
one of the funniest things white mike
does is uh
whenever it's a great place whenever
there's a team thank you shout out
that's my question uh the bangles
this [ __ ] didn't get
their numbers he'll ask his friends like
who who do you know that's a cowboys fan
he'll get all that all his friends will
send these random numbers and he'll just
text him pictures of bingles yeah
bengals bagel tigers am i saying it
right uh bengals yeah you know what i
say bingo bingles no i just want to
right
chris carter is like born and raised in
cincinnati he still says bingles okay
it's a bengals how the [ __ ] is it
spelled it's an e there's an e in there
that's your boy
that is your boy i take it very
seriously had i had a guy i would have
worn one of those on the super bowl i
was the number two biggest bengals fan
that day yeah i actually uh dm'd you the
ticket uh
i would have won like
when there were four teams oh yes i bet
on them they're plus 750 i would have
won like thirty four hundred dollars ooh
okay nick i won [ __ ] and i didn't hedge
and they did didn't have and you should
honestly we had won the game until we
didn't oh yeah and minus 200 and
[Laughter]
but at least you know at least we got
two good quarterbacks on our team we'll
be all right you know you both are
betting men
i'm yeah i got a bit of an issue yeah
yeah cheers hey yeah salud i wonder i
want 35 claws like what is this the
[ __ ] midwest
[ __ ] nothing more exciting than being
a little bit of trouble and getting your
way out of it right mike
having a gambling issue
i got a bookie that owes me no
just a bad saturday followed by uh
great son
papa digs holes on saturdays
climbs out on sunday yeah
which is a way of saying i'm better at
nfl betting yeah followed up with the
next sunday just dude college football
you're just betting on children and
you're like dude what is this this 19
year old [ __ ] kid doesn't know what i
just put on the line no you know what i
mean they don't understand they hold the
ball but they're getting paid now uh not
enough but yeah they are getting paid
how does that work college athletes you
know what i like that i'm supposed to be
the extrovert on this i have no idea i i
don't know how
like it's like a contract with
i think anybody can just pay it's very
confusing to me how it's not like murky
i feel like they can make whatever and
it's real like free market like it's
called nil and yeah they can negotiate
contracts to because they're
these universities are making money off
their name so they should actually have
been making so i mean johnny manziel
made texas a m so much money that he
didn't see now he johnny manziel's paid
in the shade anyway so he didn't need it
but like tim tebow stuff like that like
those names like rang true at those
universities and now they're able to
tell me they're making dude
i mean r.i.p but he made that university
a [ __ ] ton of money i bought it there's
like
r.i.p you guys know pat tillman no
sad story
oh you know what chance the friendly
fire
they kind of sort of hit it for a while
too so right yeah
there's a documentary that will piss you
off yeah wait really it's called but
yeah it's just about everything and his
family talked about it yeah i don't know
if i want to watch that donald rumsfeld
made made him out to be something that
he really like he was fleeing the
tillman store yeah yeah they they tried
to make it out like he was yeah
not killed by friendly fire it was like
it was just a mistake that happens to a
lot of people and they tried to make him
out to the this hero and then use that
to utilize that to recruit more people
to join the armed forces yeah
and his fam and he was the exact
opposite of that type of person one of
the coolest people ever yeah and he
would never want to lie about anything
and he liked guinness mm-hmm and
drinking did he play with jake the snake
hell yeah he did yeah they went they won
the package you know who yeah you know
jake the snake there you go and like
adam marches letter they had a good team
see i'll listen those are some names
yeah i'll have sports talks with white
mike sometimes he's probably he's
probably the only person i'll talk
sports with because i'm like
you you can explain how i am oh this
dude is he knows enough to be dangerous
in a conversation but that's exactly how
he described it you guys definitely talk
on the couch
he knows enough to be dangerous but he's
also like two follow-up questions away
from being exposed for knowing now oh
yeah yeah
but he won't do that to me
he's safe yeah anyone else i'm like yeah
that's crazy
he'll ask a question like so overtime is
what now i'm like huh
it's like and i'll be like first of all
it is overtime so don't [ __ ] talk to
me
this is i'll tell you what overtime is
this game you don't communicate with me
because this is online and papa's got
the money line
um
yeah i keep up as best as i can but
you're probably the only person that i'm
talking with yeah well i try to inform
you of what the story lines in the nba
are from month to month
yeah it's like hey steph curry's out but
he's coming back yeah playing better and
then
listen my only claim to fame that is
just surface just very service all of a
sudden just throw that out there yeah my
claim to fame
is that klay thompson follows me
clayton
does he double tap [ __ ] though he does
does he engage yes
he watches my stories and [ __ ] you guys
know clay thompson do you know meatball
mm-hmm
if he's really following me why don't
you go to clayton thomas's page no go oh
that's true that's true you know how to
spell clay thompson do you no he does
not no
he [ __ ] he did
already did he really yeah just double
clay like pottery you got screen record
on yeah cool of course i do come on
no no no no no
no
why is it with a k why is it with the k
he's blind because he's half black
i thought he was just a very large
jewish man for the longest time yeah he
does have that he's got the jackie moon
look at that
that is dope
thompson with the follow back hey you
see that bro did you hear that what do
you think of it and he's only good he's
not even following a thousand people
that's where that's true power that's
true power oh yeah he ain't following
that was a clay you need to stop playing
come on this pod i know you're in the
bay right now and he needs to we're
talking about
he's not shooting that well right no
he's doing fine we got [ __ ] white
mike on and klay thompson's following
what's up
miguelito
he's got a podcast i'm his roommate
every day he's like think about who to
have on anybody but this dude
i'm
[Music]
[Laughter]
we were on it we diverted i want to
bring it back sec the third biggest
bengals fan nicholas shea oh the shade
is the homie there's a there's a bar
called the shay's and cincy i'll get
[ __ ] up there yeah yeah just out of
respect ever met him
no i never i have not seen him not wait
till the day i meet meet him i would i
would probably freak out but i will say
and since he he's like just a scentsy
cat like i think he lives there with
vanessa
menunos
milano milano uh that's a hilarious yeah
vanessa
you're talking about yeah
[Laughter]
um well
i know we just saw somebody because we
talked about it earlier we had that same
question too yeah uh but
he's like he could run for mayor like
next week and he could oh he gets that
kind of love we love him uh he's at
bearcats games all the time but it's
funny that skyline chili
browse knows what i'm talking about oh
yeah yeah you're ohio boys right so we
had a full-on conversation i went to
shawnee state yeah 100 that's steve
johnny's shout out to portsmouth deep
cut uh yeah if you want to avoid a city
in ohio portsmouth
um but he so i was at skyline chile one
night [ __ ] up and who walks in but the
the ugliest dude from 98 degrees
the baritone i was like oh
oh the baritone what's up
nobody knows your name at all but we
know you're
you're the only if without you they'd be
100 degrees
yeah that [ __ ]
which one
what do you mean which one dude
which one you think the dude that looks
like
he'll get you an eighth of mids right
now dude for 30 bucks but it looks kind
of like they all will i'm still not 100
i don't know which one we're talking
about feel like you're feeling really
good-looking
right there with the hat
the dude that was like we're all doing
tank tops and it's like can i just stick
with the t-shirt
the hat is lachey's brother little
brother the the
hat is young lachey yeah hey what do you
think of nicholas shay's voice chin dude
that was the first like when the boy
bands came out i thought nick lachey and
and 90 degrees was [ __ ] legit because
you were in a boy band yeah and but they
were like manly were you weren't yes
we were not we're not popping we did
like seoul r b this is real yeah yeah oh
yeah he was he was really that's insane
oh were you lead singer
second lead singer
amazing yeah no you're not know your
plays elite singer now he's he's in a
group called common king his name is
jared junior king and they're killing
him right now
they're good yeah you do you like reagan
seoul r b yeah hey i like peter thompson
did i hear from you did you go
is that not heard from
i just realized bts sang english songs
yeah i don't really like when they do
that though oh so they don't always do
that no i didn't know i was even aware
of who they were and then i was like
that's been bts the whole time yeah
there's all korean but then usually when
korean pop groups get really really big
they try to cross over to america yeah
and they start having a lot of like
american features like they have uh mega
mestallion on their sure oh they do yeah
i got a question who's [ __ ] pushing
them so big
because they're on like a korean label
right yeah but i mean so their producer
was just freaking amazing at what he
does and their company i forgot who who
uh
who the who they're signed with but this
happens
pop bands though that's what i'm saying
yeah they must put them there gazillion
dollars into this this group because
they believed in them that much yeah got
it yeah that fan base is insane that's
the one fan base of 16 year olds and
like [ __ ] brazil that'll dock so
we're talking [ __ ] that's true yeah
[Music]
that's garth brooks well actually that's
i was like i know this song
bob dylan but garth brooks version of it
i'm sorry it's okay
thank you so funny he popped it up right
away too
what's your name nick oh my god
oh yeah
i'd be remiss if we brought up nick
lachey and i didn't say i do a podcast
on levi's blind
anybody watching is he on lovers bond
he's the he's the host he gets
chris harrison that's what i'm saying
this is that midwest grind you get it
this [ __ ] is he [ __ ] jessica
simpson as and has been paid since
98 degrees was never gonna make him the
money he knew he was like all right i
got a good dick i got i got this
chiseled [ __ ] i got like a jawline like
a prince from disney yeah like what's
going on and he [ __ ] jessica simpson
and he has been paid since and he got
divorced money he took half i'm sure
from her which is great
and now he's parlayed that into this
career he's still getting checks
yeah the thing i [ __ ] with the most is
that song he made when him and jessica
broke up what's left of me
oh that's such a good song dude what's
left of me like what probably quarter
mill yeah
i probably got more than that he has his
current wife in the music video playing
like jessica simpson's heart yeah you
don't play it i'm not i'll just sing it
you want to sing it go on yeah go ahead
watch my life pass me by oh damn in the
review mirror
picture frozen in time
i'm becoming clearer i don't want to
waste another day
stuck in the shadow of my mistakes
[Music]
that's good
his roommate what uh like him taking
showers is it'll literally be nick
lachey and then the next track will be
like slipknot oh yeah and then you just
want to knock on the door like
everything okay big dog
going through some stuff right now the
way it just switches up yeah you can do
that that would be like the most
aggressive music ever
my favorite slip knot album is iowa oh
what's your second favorite my second
favorite slipknot album uh
i'd probably go with the first one which
is called
this is self-titled oh they have one
they have one that are like numbers or
some [ __ ] no
that's their numbers they're one two
three
think you four five seven
trick him on a slipknot question i know
right you thought
i slipped that for halloween i didn't
know i saw him for a king of the steam
yeah i didn't
think i was going to trick him but i
wanted to hear him say i thought there
was an album called like eight six seven
nine
girlfriend's number it's a song
on the first record
uh it's it's all numbers but it's like a
sample of uh of a homegirl from
the charles manson doc saying the whole
thing i think it's sick the whole thing
i think it's sick the whole thing and
that it just repeats that like a weird
way shout out to chuckie manson yeah
still really hey yo if they just gave
them the record deal i know i blame the
beach boys for a lot of what happened
dude brian wilson killed those girls
not really but
oh
you don't think he'd run a muck with a
record deal i think he would have been
set i think that's all he wanted he just
wanted to make music i think he wanted
to make nothing and then the beach boys
were like yo let us have that track well
they took that track did he wrote a song
and then they took it yeah i know that
they were gonna give him a record deal
he didn't get it and then he's like what
if i started killing [ __ ] in the
valley and it was like all right weird
left turn but
and that's where you got to convince
other people to do it first
and then he did it if he was like in
this day and age where a lot of people
can do things independently do you think
he'd be fine or he'd still be on a
rampage see i know yeah if he was this
this day and age he'd be like justin
bieber's uh pastor he just opened it
[Laughter]
oh 100 imagine having that much power
over others
he convinced like seven people to kill
another person he never did before he
that's a that's a preacher that's a mega
church preacher yeah but if he was at
what's the uh church called uh masonic
mosaic oh and yeah and he would do like
like all rock thing too so he gets like
the
music church in hollywood right right by
runyon yeah that's what you're talking
about yeah yeah it's like the christian
that's the andrew keegan one mm-hmm ten
things i hate about you and what charles
manson was there no no no no i feel like
he could be like
as an artist yourself what did you think
of charles manson like charles manson
you think they should have just
like an artist
did you hear his music again or no um no
do you enjoy
but i went i've watched so many
interviews like i went on a charles
manson rampage
yeah
because you're like what the [ __ ] dude
yeah i i never heard an actual song i
heard him playing like guitar with the
strings kind of broke one time and i was
like
no
and you know what's [ __ ] up someone
licensed that [ __ ] and we would get
demonetized if we played charles how
much of a sniffing i mean i'm assuming
there's no way someone just deserves
that [ __ ] that's fair how much of a
snippet can we hear uh
ten seconds
enough enough to do a hurdle who only
writes to his music now
right is there like a manson estate or
something that's what i'm saying i mean
he didn't have anything
i don't know i mean i think i don't
think he needs money what's he need
money for commissary he's dead is he
dead oh is he died
in the dead
[Music]
did he get out of jail before he died or
no no he didn't get a jet out of getting
a jail free pass like checking we going
to keep you in he tried to keep he was
on good behavior for a little bit plot
twist the beach boys owned it
the conspiracy
you know where he was born and raised
come on now hey oh [ __ ] where's somebody
oh baby is he a daddy boy
that's why you guys fourth biggest
bengals fan
yeah that's why that's the connection
because you're an artist he's an artist
you're both from the [ __ ] ohio
nicholas shea nicholas we're just
talking about you you see what i'm doing
here making connections he locked
himself up before boomer
he did
oh yeah yeah he didn't even get to see
boomer boomer he killed those people
during the kenny anderson uh era of
bengals football
tough time for all of us yeah yeah the
point guard for the nets
no he was a good connection
[Laughter]
same name ken anderson he's the best
quarterback that's not in the hall of
fame one of the most accurate pastors of
all time
kenny anderson uh sports fans also true
they're so passionate they're so
passionate
i'm a nerd
mma that's it it makes nothing that's as
far as you go for real yeah seriously
it's taken over my all my i grew up
football basketball now it's all i don't
watch
football uh i don't think those are the
same thing no
definitely not the same thing but you
lost
the other one's like how about 11 on 11.
but it's like also brutal all of them
are super brutal it's almost brutal
sports right they got they got pads on
oh but they're way more fast and hard
dude yeah i don't know i think i just
don't have the bandwidth i'm so like
emotionally invested in like these
things where i'm like
at a point where i'm like do i need to
add this stress to my life every
saturday it's a stress and i don't i
don't need that and it's seven hours
yeah but i if you for a gambling man
though there's nothing it's
nothing like it i've done it 15 minutes
i know i should be into it if you
watched one card with me you would be an
mma fan we'd be gambling
i'm trying to date mikey
i'm in a committed relationship and
sometimes i'm thinking about my
bandwidth like if i started being this
person is this person going to stay with
me probably not
i mean hey
it's something you should check it out i
let i let really i like girls i'm
talking to know like saturdays
for the
saturdays i'm going to watch two men
very lightly clothed just [ __ ] go at
it and you are encouraged and welcome to
watch but if you don't want to watch
that's where i will be i don't know
saturday are the rules
do you lay down like a set of rules for
if they watch with you like no talking
no i'll teach all day yeah ask questions
do you watch it at all
i will watch mma fights here and there
i'm much more of a casual fan now i used
to watch quite often but not anymore
i just i just started watching this i
mean while i've been watching like like
here and there it's tough i just get so
stressed out my heart starts racing you
know
money i like i like boxes i think boxing
is fun because i know there's going to
only be one or two good fights a year so
i'm like i'll make some time that's easy
yeah yeah yeah you have seas like every
saturday yeah we got the yeah they got
like the dopest fights we work on
saturday i can't get enough like yeah
yeah remember we watched the we went to
that bar and watched the fury wilder
yeah i love i love a good boxing match
that was good that was fun
ufc doesn't get me going i don't know i
like i grew up on like wwf and [ __ ] like
that so i like that so they're usually
but that doesn't transfer over to the no
because i did like i did like grown men
in like underwears like for a long time
hey shout out to the rock uh chris
jericho with the thigh-high boots too
yeah do they have thigh-high boots on
this too no no no unfortunately i don't
think they got low-tops
no shoes oh no shoes no shoes in the
beginning they did they could wear like
less issues in the beginning yeah really
but not anymore they used to wear ghees
and stuff too didn't they yeah old
school uh gracie talking about crazy
early earlier that's og that's a phoenix
boy how'd you know that because i see
gracie i lived by uh one of their
studios oh [ __ ] i don't know if they're
phoenix people but i know that they were
big in arizona yeah i don't know much
about it i know i mean
it's whatever
ken gracie's like the dude that started
they say like
put it on the map in a larger way i know
why ufc stresses me out
because i'm such a geek for those
martial art films
and i love those things like the old
school dubbed ones
then i come to find out that
that you know you can't really fight
that way that's not right that's not
true that's that's true you think they
can really fight that way in a real
fight let me show you stephen
wonderboard thompson let me show you no
but he knows
oh he
but he thought it would be good for his
jab and then his power punch would be
the regular hand meanwhile he came there
thinking about hands he was getting
kicked in
yeah yeah i'm pretty sure that's the
dude he looks like peanut butter cup
from 51st dates
i'm not talking about the guy that is
tooth kicked out i know there's another
guy i was spacing i was trying to get
someone else to tell okay the guy in the
diner
[Laughter]
is that him yeah that's him right there
and let's see if he has an mma record
yeah really he does all right
ufc mm-hmm you know what i'm saying he
lost weight
no i don't know about that definitely
not no it looks like it he lost that he
lost that fight he lost is he the guy
who says the name of the
fish in yeah creating ceremony no
yeah the bartender yeah no i don't think
he's that racist the black dude does
yeah it's a black dude because someone
showed me that clip so that's not racist
at all no no completely different
i thought it was a big but is that guy
you're talking that guy's a big guy yeah
but is that guy in for getting sarah
marshall the big black dude no the one
that says that that's because
no i know the big black face on love
i think we might be racist to be honest
no i think this hawaiian guy is also one
for getting sarah marshall in a
different part he's like the guy who
like yeah another hong kong right yeah
yeah yeah not not the ufc wang okay
another one guy yeah but i know you're
talking about are most asian people
racist against other asian people yeah
absolutely yeah that's what's up his
people are racist against my people
i'm vietnamese it's a black guy right
yeah i'm like southeast asian like
uh jungle asian a little known for being
like a little dirtier third worldly he's
like the precious asian yeah he's korean
what are you doing we're live
yeah the bts
we're fair-skinned
and we're communists
innocent and he well he's hovering
around communism though yeah aren't you
what are you just south of communism i
don't know because i'm like one
just adjacent one sip away from
communism that's what's up one step away
that's good
i do like asians in uh california i've
always noticed are the coolest asians
really um what are asians like in ohio
uh not cool because
i've heard that before like asians
outside of california are very different
i always say like the asians in san
francisco was the first time i was like
y'all look cool as [ __ ] yeah i've never
looked at an asian and looked at their
shoes and been like i should buy those
um david sews like the coolest guy
oh yeah davidson is [ __ ] dope it's
interesting california asians they got
it figured out um yeah asians in ohio
it's like oh what's up with the math
homework from yesterday yeah um i worked
i worked with uh
asians and uh orange when i lived in
orange county yeah a lot of asians yeah
a lot of republican agents majority like
them yeah a lot of us are uh very
conservative and a lot of them love
trump in orange county that's what's up
yeah so you see a lot of like an orange
county thing yeah i mean hey half the
country voted for yes i i think it's the
orange county thing but i will say
there's a lot of asian trump supporters
in san jose as well
yeah yeah well think about it back home
in arizona there's a lot of mexican
trump supporters there's a lot i mean
very true there's a lot of trump
supporters there's a lot uh i always
think it's funny but these people
supported trump was like he won an
election
and he almost won another one
like there's only white people
i'd love to yeah that was my favorite
thing when people were shocked it's like
oh so you've never been to kansas or
ohio yeah iowa there's a lot of people
that like the guy oh come on now but
yeah the you can feel it when we go out
on on the road yeah you know you laugh
at the wrong parts of my jokes yeah yeah
yeah you're like like that was actually
like yeah i was actually making fun of
you guys
i'm on twitter way too much and sure i
could sense that energy yeah yes uh and
uh it's mine it's my newspaper yeah wake
up um
i've got it curated pretty good so i i
have a good time on my feed that's
actually where that's where i heard
about uh hurdle today someone was like
if you don't get it on the first second
you ain't [ __ ] yeah
[Music]
i think hurdles neutral
to people who play i was just trying to
be a fan of everybody yeah but uh the
other day there was like this uh
in the midst of like world war
war
nfl free agency
going on right now this way here i
haven't heard uh but there was like this
article that was in like a bunch of
different places like one of those pr
blasts but it was like
uh plans to be the first national
hispanic conservative
uh
uh talk radio station sure and the the
sub lopez the sub headline was like uh
defcon won for the left
and everybody like roasted the headline
because it was a bad time to say defcon
won when putin's throwing around the
idea of nukes and [ __ ] sure but the the
point is
we're waiting for that yeah conservative
hispanics is like liberals are worried
they will lose this base because
everybody doesn't expect hispanics to be
liberals took too long
liberals should just be concerned that
they just they have just assumed that
every minority is like we're liberal
it's like
you can't keep just [ __ ] not giving
them anything and assuming they're
liberal
[Laughter]
like say what you will about kanye maybe
[ __ ] with trumpet is like he's at least
saying like they're not helping black
people no they're they're claiming there
but uh you know i have a black roommate
so i know
and a black girlfriend and a black
girlfriend yeah i understand i'm burying
the league
very progressive hey yeah he's beating
everybody out here come on now he's
[ __ ] you know i understand yeah this
is why mike right i understand a lot i
understand tina turner beyonce
have you seen the uh what's love got to
do with the document or not documentary
the biopic yeah back in the day that was
so good one of my favorite romantic
comedies
you're gonna eat the cake man yeah
have you guys ever seen don't take the
name the name got my daddy's blood on it
yeah you know that was a disney film
that was not a dude disney produced that
movie that's dope they produced that
movie yeah
yo fans anyone listening if you've never
seen what's love shout out to larry
fishburne
hey i always say
my name is mike turner you can call me
ike turner from rocking a wife beater
hey hey come on now and they put that
[ __ ] wig on uh
he wasn't in the new uh matrix
he wasn't he said peace the reason why i
forget what it was did y'all know there
was a new matrix i did i heard about it
i did not see it didn't watch it isn't
that sad
he wasn't in it no no
they recast morpheus oh
because this was a younger version right
wouldn't it be a younger version no it
was no cause
keanu reeves was still there he was the
only guy who could have replaced grisham
um csi
oh love csi
this guy replaced him
crime scene investigation
i mean i'm familiar with what csi means
the television show the tv show
that's the guy who played the new
morpheus yeah 30 year old running
franchise on cbs cs
i don't watch uh
those 24.
uh
they got no twenty-four properties
yeah oh uh
no i never watch anything on any of the
networks it was a joke that i kept
referring to it would have to keep
talking it's hard
because
like i'll be watching it and my girl
will be like what about watching 9-1-1
i'm like what about not you know
you know that was a nice procedure
is that the um the live
pd or whatever no 9-1-1 is like just
like the most aggressive emergency you
can think of in your mind and they'll
just film that and it'll be like but rob
lowe's in it and you're like all right
i'm oh it's oh it's a script it's a
scripted show
okay i've often got that confused with
the 90s classic rescue911 which that is
well that was like early 2000s because
it was actually about 911. but uh dennis
leary no uh that is
it was a a real show it was like a cops
first responders oh yeah uh one that
sticks out in my mind i was like six
this girl got her tongue stuck in a like
coke bottle like doing suction
and they had to like do surgery because
they can't just smash it or her tongue
will bleed and your tongue doesn't like
stop bleeding it's the slowest part of
your mouth to stop bleeding the rest of
it is the fastest in your body
interesting in a coke bottle with like
the plastic
glass glass so they couldn't just smash
it oh [ __ ]
they smashed it wouldn't they just
shatter and then they could they should
have your [ __ ] hair just leave you
know she probably i don't know how long
but that sounds like the origin story of
gene simmons tongue
yeah i'm saying that's a deep cut i told
you guys i have a long tongue you do i
saw we saw it so i see that i missed my
i missed people ask all the time you
people you know that you got a long time
yeah you'll show it
oh damn actually that is a long time
that's a super long tongue i don't know
how that happened very sharp it just
happened
should we be kissed for halloween
i'll do it i'll be honest how many
members are in kiss
would be my guess it's four yeah four
i'll do white face kisses four yeah
yeah
we still do it like
slipknot just a bunch of different kiss
members yeah i was slipknot i know what
did you ever watch that movie detroit
rock city yeah that was a good movie you
know
my favorite favorite was uh
no i
i was getting a diver because i missed a
segway earlier when we were talking
about soulful music i was gonna be like
we got a music contest but i also want
to hear your last name that's the point
i forgot what i was going to say hey
damn damn well perfect talking about
perfect time detroit
rock city i was just talking about how i
loved uh airheads airheads is a good
movie air has a [ __ ] love here
with uh adam sandler brennan fraser
treasurer in uh steve he was yeah
awesome
and uh
who's the chick in that oh airheads also
also
who is the chick in that
annie locain
yeah maybe
nina oh michael mccain i'm not even
going to oh yes
that was a good [ __ ] movie also
probably hasn't aged well what do you
say what does he say who wouldn't win in
a fight let me hear god well just a
bunch of rock stars one time uh michael
mckean was on the adam corolla show and
adam carolla is obsessed with his uh
no ravens are super smart uh or cross
cross yeah
extremely smart and uh huh
and he wants to use like attack crows
it's like a bit he's had for years and
he was telling michael mckean about this
and he was just like blown away and he
didn't believe crows were smart and for
like years after that uh i would would
every time there was an article about
crow doing something crazy i tweeted at
him
that's who you are so now he knows
they are crazy i mean they figure out
[ __ ] with they use sticks and stuff and
they also use displacement to raise
things out yeah it's like what
displacement [ __ ] catapult what
learned that in 11th grade i can't i
can't even use it myself yo when nick
gets onto something he [ __ ] locks in
yeah i mean he's right now his biggest
commitment is [ __ ] corey feldman it
looks like it's the packers
that's a lifelong endeavor uh but
corey feldman i'm off we're we've moved
on and the
michael mckean was not an obsession you
don't come across uh crow's being smart
article every single day it's like once
every couple of months but yeah you
talked to my uncle
michael duff has a bunch of crows in his
backyard in flagstaff he named him it's
actually concerning we're talking about
him uh we're bringing them up at
thanksgiving this year uh it's like dude
are you good
you're naming crows and counting them i
think nice
what i was waiting for i was like come
on somebody speaking of airheads uh it's
a long it's a long december uh
the this other podcast that uh
my friends are on it's called the water
cooler they had to debate
favorite fictional band like in a movie
there's a lot you start throwing out a
lot of names spinal tab final tap it's
probably the best
uh i would also say is the zack attack
checkout that's the type of [ __ ] we're
talking about
about
rockstar
is called rockstar
i think that's a good band
right there oh dude what about the the
abandoned um
what's that kate hudson movie almost
famous
that's a good thing uh
i stole their show now i stole their
[ __ ] great debate
isn't rockstar based on a band though an
actual band
no that's creedence clearwater revival
look up almost famous
billy crudup was this lead singer
meatball got almost you've got meatball
fingers over there you guys
i'm typing over there i do got fat
fingers you do that's what's up that's
what's up i just got fat sausage fingers
that's all what is the band's name
cameron crow also fantastic film and
that was a good need to answer
put band
they were good uh
real steel water still water so i think
they were named i think they're named
after creedence clearwater revival
ccr that's a good real band
do you guys like the band
oh yeah hey come on hey come on now
last waltz
wait so uh
because i forgot what i was going to
talk about anyway what was your segway
you had uh for the music contest we're
going to reveal the winner yeah that's
the music contest the winner
are you in a music contest we did a
music contest on here the winner gets to
be on the thick boy album let's drop in
later this month and we were down to two
contestants
um
billy crudup did notice something a
little interesting talk to him now so
let him know when we first posted the
poll
uh contestant number two was winning
then when we reposted it
contestant five somehow took the lead
and i noticed that he was going around
getting his boys to tag a minute uh
tagging like he was tagging his boys
saying vote for me so it's a little iffy
on who really did win
are you not allowed to ask people to
vote
i mean we never said that because they
do that on american idol yeah
yeah they they have some [ __ ] texts
i don't hate that five six seven eight
and [ __ ] you know what i mean they have
that under there sure
shout out to reuben studdard hey oh come
on sorry for 2004. austin do you also
know the artist names of the uh
which one's two which one's five brian
has two artists
okay wow these are young men
young men
rapping already and yeah
is this a specific to rap contest or is
it just it was open to anything but uh
they were both kind of wrapped the
second guy sang a little bit more would
you compare it to like uh uh
everlasting everlast oh that's sad
this guy's winning
maybe he is cheating i don't know
you gotta hear it though mike yeah he's
out of here he's good he's got bars oh
yeah we support everybody
so
i've got nothing to say
right it is my roommate yeah
miguelito blanco yeah
estonian caballero
there you go
this is the position this is number two
this was uh this does have everlasting
energy already watch yeah
wait watch where you hear it
his voice dude oh dude kev gonna get him
on next week
shout out to markham's shout out to
virgos
bars bars mars bars
my man's in the park talking about the
city
yeah he alone talking about
relationships it's a lot of
contradictory energy going on
[Music]
[Music]
that's not bad and he produced this
himself
that's a good good beat there too yeah
and then this is contestant number five
oh this is arthur right yeah this is
some uh kanye and uh what's that you
doing
little pump energy yeah
oh what the [ __ ]
he made a whole
i think he just superimposed his head
like he put his head on some other video
i don't think this is actually the video
also he got adobe
yeah man got premiere because look at
that i don't think that's him those
better be his cars i don't think it is
because think about it you never really
see him walking like normally
it's just him
except right there oh he dropped
chapelle on there he's actually in the
music video and then they edited his
head to look bigger in certain shots
yeah are you sure that's not the little
pump kanye video no that was definitely
not the little it's definitely not there
it's not that oh you're thinking it's
that no it's not that
they were wearing something this guy
this guy did this all yeah yeah he fully
shot a music video yeah he rented a car
he went to turo for that
yeah that big my man does not know
anybody that i don't like
i don't know if he just put juice but is
my man's name juice box
i think it's a juice box production
oh this is arthur and then that's it
and 92 what's the poll right now
i'm weirdly more in on everlast
oh you exactly dude that was my vote
that actually is weird
i [ __ ] love the other guy's video but
i like the music of the uh
like a more legit what is his real name
i gotta call him by this brian brian but
he does have a difficulty of like an
artist named he goes by oh oh oh oh 860.
okay so we'll get rid of this he's from
the 860. yeah he's from connecticut
what about what if we put a boat on a a
track together
um you're not a battery i can cut that
if you want
he does edit it
there's some clashing styles there's
some clashing styles i don't think
they're feeling that that guy could pay
for his own
to make his own track or send it
to the album
we'll record you know
we can cut that out i just want to be
fair i want like the better person to
like to win especially if someone's in a
competition they're like yo i want to be
no one wants a [ __ ] draw you think
tyson is such a draw hold up my man's
got him i'll bring out the fight my
man's got 154 followers and he's winning
this
he had that he had that vibe no he's
losing he's losing oh oh oh oh this
guy's but it's like a losing and a weird
oh that's kind of controversial
okay
oh that's why oh uh oh is everlasting
damn he posted this too
uh-oh is struggling but that's tough
because we ask for a vote and people are
voting
from your people yeah because he's
getting poor people
hey
you had your month
it's
technically my month i think it's
women's month no
you got a day yeah that was yesterday
yeah
you got one month
call me me back i have a solution
uh we
confirm with brendan and we can to put
this on the fighter and the kid
uh instagram because then we'll get more
votes where i don't think either one of
these people can move the needle with
their friends that's a personal attack
on both of their names what i mean
that's what we're looking for we're
looking for something like unknown and
this only has seven dollars
why don't we throw this on the kingdom
that's what i'm thinking because this
cat's after dark however there's we
could do both it gets trickier
with the king and the sting at the
moment
no follow-up questions
uh-oh
connecticut he got a la hat see these
are there's a lot of cross signals on
his oh no i was wrong we'll rock the new
york hat the yankees well that would
make more sense if he's in connecticut
and being a yankee head i think he's
pandering
to uh us in california can i connecticut
you gotta wear a boston hat not yankees
hat really you know how close they are
to new york though i'm from rhode island
well that sounds like a personal problem
no i'm saying it's boston [ __ ] [ __ ] new
york yeah like hey chill hey whoa
all right okay long island kids just get
so [ __ ] i know 50 cent lived in
connecticut yeah yeah he will murder
somebody from boston based on his early
2000s
really 5-0
double quarters that's crazy say
anything about me and chappelle i always
say chapel got a little 50-cent animal
yeah i do he looks like him yeah if
there's a really understated way to to
tell him about gianni's career he works
for 50 seconds oh sorry he's an actor on
uh on power no i think that's funny that
was cool that was cool
power he's in the power universe yeah he
was originally on power
he was originally on power and then he
got the lead in the spin-off powerpuff
two ghosts
oh oh i know who he is braden yeah yeah
the the gary owen
yeah no no no no no no not gary
oh not tommy yeah it's not going to
happen it's not
no not tommy that is gary owen first of
all
he's in ozark too
oh i don't know him also should i watch
the show just be honest you know this
you're obviously biased
people love this show people love power
tim are the spin-offs that's him with
fat joe and spike lee yeah i would have
gotten fat joe
spike can i just get
dylan says power is for bender who
uh yeah he likes it he's like says it to
gianni he's like i know he's or he said
it about gianni as pakistan i know that
he gets to do a great he's a star
if you watch power you're a dumb person
there's some story lines where you're
like all right this is i i get what he's
saying on that i'm sure i haven't
watched it ever but i understand the
critique of that
i mean when i'm watching snowfall
snowfall is for educated folks mm-hmm um
who else it's very different i'm trying
to put you on a snowflake yeah i think
you did it it's in our area because it's
about crack cocaine epidemic it's also
about how the cia was definitely
involved
it's all these things shout out to
snowfall shout out to damsom idris yeah
he probably watches
and we're not too far from south central
yeah we live you know what i go to
englewood for breakfast a lot
shout out to pans shout out to pans
north inglewood
nor okay i can't go too deep
no you used to go to school in south
central it's always really funny because
usc is a private school
with a bunch of like rich kids who would
then like walk on the wrong like a block
too far or go south campus yeah
it's one hilarious and so also like
scary to watch like some
child who like does not know where
they're going that you could just like
scoot in a bird around yes campus some
campus i mean you've been to university
of cincinnati's campus yeah so that [ __ ]
is like it's in clifton in cincinnati
and it's like
i don't know growing up you just
wouldn't really go down there for other
than to see kenyon martin and uh you
know pay your respects and watch the
basketball team but it was like it's
like that same [ __ ] you get off campus
it's like yeah we are in over there you
know it's not like that asu asu is not
like that at all you could walk five
miles anyway and you're like is there
any minorities anything yeah
just looking for a minority how would it
be a brunette is a minority there yeah
that is a minority at asu shout out to
asu though good times good times
mm-hmm
good morning
what are we deciding then
i think we do another poll and then
and i don't think that's like
any any bait and switch or anything
we're just it's a bigger poll it's the
same thing we're putting out to a fan
vote i think that's fair
let's do that yeah yeah because i do not
believe we got that many views i think
like we only got like
500 so i mean it says so many votes
doesn't it
yeah yeah me
just not on that account because it's
not signed it let me check
yeah because if something has like 500
views the votes are probably somewhere
in the like 200s so it has 73 for brian
and then 178 for arthur
the analytic queen
sorry i'm good with numbers
how'd you say it of course
dark knight he's like i'm extremely good
and i'm not going to do his voice with
calculations
yeah dark knight is that uh the guy that
they went to they wouldn't extradite
from from china she's a batman i i
haven't i haven't seen it yet i hear
your voice
it was good i liked it a lot i was like
blown away how do you feel about zoey
kravitz as catwoman come on now i can't
i got a girl
i i hope she makes a spin-off is what
i'm doing there's an article
about her auditioning for the dark
knight and i guess she wasn't
auditioning for catwoman she was
auditioning for a different role a
smaller role and she was told like oh
we're actually going a different
direction we're not going urban and this
story blew up and she was
saying this in an interview basically to
show how
times have changed with casting
and i guess it got her into some hot
water because people were [ __ ] on
christopher nolan after that she had to
go on instagram say like hey this is
just to say like casting has changed i'm
not saying anyone's racist like please
stop running with the story i love that
it's like it's we're we're not trying to
go urban it's like gotham city is the
definition of urban yeah
that is the most urban environment i've
ever seen in my life with
some of the worst cops i've ever heard
of this can we talk about gotham cops
are the worst cops
in the history of cops in fictional cop
writing ever not a single one of them
they're really taking money
damn 100 they're all bought
yeah serpaco
make cerbico again and put it in gotham
i thought she was amazing
i thought i thought it was the best
casting they've done in
um well no they christopher nolan did
really well with cassidy obviously but
you like the val kilmer one
this was great
i actually like val kilmer was solid
solid batman i think that the writing
and the directing in those movies was
the biggest problem like the vision that
they wanted to do with batman in the
late 90s tim burton
uh keaton was the [ __ ] oh yeah he was
the second one is amazing with danny
devito as penguins yeah but this one was
great and it also not it doesn't spoil
anything but it doesn't dwell on the
fact that his parents were killed yeah
how many times do we need to kill his
parents all right
guys got a lot of trauma uncle ben from
spiderman has also died enough yeah yeah
yeah i love batman all right
pattinson i'm a big pattinson guy ever
since he made good time yeah who is him
who's better
him or christian bale uh that's uh
a good question i think christian bale
really i i'm a keaton guy honestly which
is weird christian
christian bale he really did it really
well he gave it a new here's what i
would say is it's completely he the best
thing is that you can do when you're the
batman is make it make it your own and
he clearly made it his own i actually
think ben affleck gets hated on too much
i thought he was a great
bruce wayne i think people get lost when
he turns into batman he did one better
he was right he did too he did too
he was good as batman but i think the
movies around him were ass yes if that
makes sense yes those productions
sounded like a mess also like the whole
thing sounded messy just like andrew
garfield was a great spider-man but
those movies were terrible how was he
the best spider-man he was was in the
third one when he was like the tertiary
yeah yes not just i mean it's been out
it's been out for a while that's fine
that you spoiled it for me though you
weren't gonna also look uh this batman
is great because it's like
it's like he's [ __ ] dude you brought
up csi
my man's got a crime to solve and i'm
like [ __ ] it it reminded me i grew up
watching wb after uh school yeah
the block was batman then superman and
it just reminded me of those cartoons
and i was like [ __ ] yeah dude did you
[ __ ] with jackie chan adventures uh
jackie chan movies adventures adventures
oh never mind
oh yeah we had a cartoon yeah
it was good yeah i remember i did i'm
i'm like 35 so i don't remember that i
don't it's an older channel
all the time so i was like aware of
jackie chan
yeah
uh that was when he was fading
but yeah that was good it was a movie he
did super super pop or something like
that and he did uh
rum on the bronx
um the tuxedo
there's some good ones i'm losing tim we
need to do rush hour i know what do you
mean me and [ __ ] what does that mean do
russia oh the film again we need a
remake our versions i mean do rush hour
we got thick boy studios here we can
[ __ ] use this room for some [ __ ] oh
you know you can write a pitch for it i
mean
this could be an interrogation room no
problem i know right yeah bro we got the
perfect setup chris
chris
who's the villain yeah we need a vet the
vampire right there
hey gently
still alive
jeffy was the villain in every movie
i know that's not true
i can't deny that or guarantee so okay
so the batman's hard voucher batman our
thing is to officially do it
on another
one of our instagram accounts and then
we'll go off that put on my boy i got
six thousand followers i got y'all hours
and seven minutes
i think that's good timing yeah that's
perfect all right guys thank you guys
for tuning in we got we all got plugs
right oh and we have we're going to put
this in the front of the show that was
promised oh mike you ever heard of magic
mine you guys tell them about it magical
magic i love magic mike you want to be a
magician well ain't going to do that i
hate magic you hate magic i mean but
that's a different thing we're not doing
magic right no we're not doing no but
we're going to get focused without
getting wired okay our minds though
don't trust magicians magic
what's your distrust of magicians
because they they are walking into the
situation knowing they're trying to
trick me [ __ ] that yeah they're coming
trying to make me look dumb also who
needs like you need a quarter that
sounds concerning yeah and who has lose
change
we're in a
shortage yeah yeah it's like dude i
don't have a loose change well you gotta
need a quarter dude that's really
concerning pick a card
why
i don't like magic talk about magic yeah
yeah yeah
i'm not my magic mind hey pass it around
man hey this that [ __ ] oh now you're
coming here
i need it now you need it
when i first took this [ __ ] y'all was
[ __ ] up
this isn't a great sell
it's green
i promise mike you'll be fine is it good
does it taste good hey rob just ate if
you've got a white man when
[Music]
he's hovering oh he's hovering oh that's
blair witch
that's how that's how the player which
ends you can do that tomorrow spoiler
alert yeah so white mike the thing about
magic mine is is there a thing yeah it's
yeah i know what do you do you shake it
good shake it again
like that and look and you got your
white claw right there if you want to
chase a little bit if it tastes a little
the taste isn't bad dude i don't know
we'll check it out look at that how the
[ __ ] did that happen i do mushrooms so
what
is that
that's magic right there that's how that
happened is there mushrooms in it
yeah uh
oh matcha cordyceps
honey cortisone cordyceps mushrooms
adaptogens
that sounds like a made-up ashwagandha
hey you ever been on echinacea
yeah that's evanescence
you got evanescence in them i do not
think evanescus is one of the 12 let's
not let's not disrespect the sponsor hey
matt uh but anybody could get their
magic mind at magicmind.com
use promo code dark for 20 off promo
codec for 20 off magic mine take your
shots shout out to cheers shout out to
imaginewise cheers white mike hey
to white magic mike
shout out to nick
shouts out to 98 degrees 90 degrees they
could have been 100 if they didn't have
the homie
drew lachey it uh it honestly gets
better every single time it really does
look i'm not even saying this to be a
promo i hated this at first do you drink
it
really don't drink matcha i thought you
i thought you did matcha jessica does
much oh shout out to my girl jessica you
watching girl what's up
it's your month
and it was your month last month
but black women
but two months in a row right before we
sign off
we keep talking about the magic it
actually will just help you focus
throughout the day a nice zen hum uh
anti-procrastination drink it's not
[ __ ] i swear to god there's hope
it's all gone it's all about beyond
coffee written by james bashara who's uh
the ceo and the friend of the show
shout out james shout out to our
beautiful sponsor take it alongside your
morning caffeine yeah
oh you want to play it
if you want yeah well you got to prepare
yourself i didn't know if you wanted to
wait for the lyric video or not i i
think we i think we could play it we
could play it what's your new song we'll
go outside
also
my sponsor that most likely will be our
sponsor now hey
today i'm shout out to jerome from into
the m all the tools i wear what did you
see this into the a.m you it's a huge
company you'll if you google it you'll
know what it is or if you do coke you
know what that means
no i don't i don't want to associate the
two no no
you're you're actually working hard into
the night to become successful
into the night but uh maybe in what i
mean so premium teas
right shriek resistant colors always pop
here's some examples right here wow
that's a pop tart right there
they're all just kid cuddy albums yeah
what is this how to say that like
[Applause]
oh my god so go to into the am dot com
slash chin and you'll get 10 off an
additional 10 off your entire order hey
yeah yeah hell yeah hell yeah
there'll be a link in the description
right nick
yeah link in the description send that
to me yeah we get are we getting some
some swag
cool and we'll get pretty boy no he just
want to show us all his swag that he got
we don't get any no
oh working on are you are you don't
worry about it you being clever
now what are we going to fight right now
oh cats fight club coming soon we can
just talk and just one minute rounds
we'll just spar back there yeah it's all
fair ones
what do you don't need a commentator i'm
right here each other i just need to let
it out i thought you're saying like any
punch is like fair we're gonna say no
like i don't want to get punched in the
dick but it's on that note
oh anything you want that's the music
can you open it oh yeah we got something
oh wait i mean i got vegetables we could
take it out with this yeah made a song
for magic mine shout out to magic mine
oh what
you got to like bump it though run it
back
yeah get your vibes right get your focus
oh yeah
make that mind magical shout out to
brown like as soon as i sip it magic
mind about to make the whole day hit
different wake up and go and get it
clarity when i think first time i ever
really felt productive when i drink oh
yeah
mixing up the matcha with the honey make
it hit oh more stress let's live a
better life
making magic drinking magic mine
okay i'm feeling good okay i'm feeling
great hey come on
south ohio
oh yeah
this [ __ ] changed shawnee stayed into a
ivy league school
okay i'm feeling great what's got me
feeling good what's helping me to think
you know it's magic mine good vibes
thank you guys for tuning in every week
every sunday these episodes come out
around a sporadic time sporadic time you
know what it is it's cats after dark
baby what do you what do you expect yeah
sometime after sunset on sometimes after
yeah after sunday you know uh thank you
guys for tuning in oh uh i will be
when does this come out sunday sunday oh
i'll already be done the dates but i'll
promote my utah dates april 8th and
april 9th i'll be in salt lake city utah
at um wise guys get tickets at
chapellelacey.com
and then in may san diego new comedy
club in san diego that i'm doing called
mic drop comedy club i'm with you and
hey guess what white mike if you enjoyed
him on the show he will be out there
with him i'll be opening he'll be the
night before this week's accident yeah
he'll be opening the club night before
and then uh he'll be he'll be featuring
for me stand up something and that's may
5th 6th success what does it say
commander 6th and 7th oh may 6th and may
7th uh san diego and then i'm doing a
one night or may 12th in my hometown are
you doing phoenix yeah
mike what else what else you got coming
up besides shows with chappelle i'm
doing that i got i'll be in austin at
the end of the month
uh for like a week so if anybody's in
austin i'll be there popping around and
then i'll be opening up for our homie
trevor wallace in durham and in atlanta
yeah uh april 1 and 2.
um
one thing about white mike he's a really
funny comedian super super funny you can
see his videos on his instagram
the man on the street [ __ ] is so funny
so funny
he's a really funny dude i give this
dude a lot of love and i hope he just
continues to grow and gets like a lot of
success
continually is funny and i you know
would love for you all to support them
as much as you support us appreciate
y'all yeah chat
uh oh yeah oh uh yeah if you want to see
pictures of my feet onlyfans.com
no promo code that's a promo
oh my god i never even thought about
that you should do that for sure get set
up by sunday promo code dark promo code
dark yeah
how much percent off
[Laughter]
yeah it's actually
it's actually him trying to hide it
because he's already i know he's already
said
so is it only
only fans
yeah and it's only feet uh yeah actually
it started out as feet now i just do
like the basic instagram [ __ ] thing i
love it yeah good for you thanks have
fun it's hey it's your month it's my
month let me do as life weeks you know
christian
uh you can just find me on instagram at
see halo 6 and that's really it
awesome yeah you're cr you were crushing
it ha ha comedy club too oh yeah i've
been up and coming come here
i actually left before you get up
though it was it was my i had done an
open mic before then but that was like
the first show i've ever done because i
was like thinking about like if he was
just kind of like all right i'm out dude
good kill okay
i thought i didn't know you were just
starting yeah that was my first show
ever
yeah yeah you had to follow your boy
[Laughter]
yeah i was talking tough
[Laughter]
i had him popping up front it had to be
tough i haven't even heard about this
go around
people yeah no it's not gonna just
called you out i apologize no no we can
edit this out
and browse instagram little brow spotify
low brows uh thick boy album later this
month and pre-saves will be available
soon
uh the second round of the ncaa
tournament saturday and sunday uh me and
my buddy are gonna be at my house just
streaming on his his twitch channel
twitch.com slash t underscore darsh i
mean it's very passive companion viewing
but i might i might take down three i
pull up
we got a spot brother come through
i want to have a rotating group of
guests i would i would love it i love
marshmallows i might i might just chris
no 19 year old [ __ ] like what
the [ __ ] are you doing
i might crush 36 claws
this weekend what was that yeah i was
the most excited i've ever seen nick i
know his eyes we got a spot brother
come on through brother
silver like anybody wants to pull up
he doesn't look too far from addressing
no i'm just kidding
all right all right are we good
all right have a good one love you all
[Music]
[Music]
you